did you throw out a first pitch yet yeah  i threw it on in 2010 when the one  that's coming started  before and it's farther than it is  yeah i know and i threw a knuckleball  because i wanted to throw a knuckleball  but did you really know oh yeah they  didn't reach the plate you took your one  opportunity to throw a knuckleball bro  i got you bro  i got to do for the dodger my dad used  to follow the dodgers in mexico and then  when he came over here he took us to our  first dodger game started working here  like in the 90s yeah i work here for  many years and i never thought i'd be  throwing the first pitch because i like  to throw hot dogs i remember some lady  ate half a hot dog and spotted the other  half back and said this was an edible  and i said which part the party didn't  eat  oh  different when you're throwing to that  hell man yeah  hopefully i'll get our espn